[Musica]
va beh
se nessuno
mi è sembrato di sentire qualcosa qua in
camera che cosa si fa il mio libro
aperto qua
qualcuno ha preso è aperto il mio libro
forse è stato solo vitale vitale
[Applauso]
sei stato tu ad aprire il mio libro e la
sarro qua sul comodino aperto a privato
libro che l'acqua qualcuno l'ha aperto
qualcuno l'ha letto no non sono stato io
[Musica]
ma no saranno gli uccelli o
[Risate]
c'è qualcos'altro ma io sono un amico di
me fino a berlino è un suo amico che è
entrato dentro casa o sei forse giù che
stavi annusando
non è un amico di berlino
mi sa di no
[Musica]
logo
questo
è dietro questo bordo basso
ci sono dei graffi degli ululati credo
che ci sia un lungo dentro
pensa un po io pensavo fossero i tubi
dell'acqua che non andavano bene
i giorni dell'alba
al mio tre abbiamo la porta vediamo dice
qua dentro che 12
chi
è
scusate ma
talmente vedi sono voluto andare in
bagno
piacere potete gentilmente
leale ti aspetto a questo momento
finalmente
vorrei un momento per me grazie se non
vi dispiace
cosa
con il lupo il bagno
sul gabinetto
favore
si scusa noi non volevamo disturbare
solo che in teoria sarebbe casa nostra e
questo è il nostro bagno e da dove è
uscito
a insomma dove due momento abbiamo
compagni li abbiamo
ma che cosa è appena successo
[Musica]
chi era quello lo avete visto un lupo
sul gabinetto sicuramente ha qualcosa a
che fare col libro perché sapete che nel
mio libro ci sono anche i lupi i lupi
mannari
forse la risposta è proprio nel mio
libro a proposito lo avete già preso è
disponibile in tutte le librerie e su
amazon se non l'avete ancora preso
storie paurose ascolati misteri andate
subito a prenderlo non potete non averlo
stories family e ora cerchiamo una
soluzione con il libro forse in una
delle schede creatura cima idea
allora finito speriamo che si lavi le
mani poi dopo le
zampe
scusate
ma
chi sei tu e ragazzi e altre lunga
adesso vi spiego tutto io sono l'ex lupo
l'ex mag dopo l apostrofo ex o l'ex
tutto unito no non l'ex nel senso che
era un lupo perché come vedi io sono
mezzo lupo e mezzo umano quindi non è
l'ex l apostrofo ex è l'ex tutt
attaccato il mio nome che cosa centri
con il mio libro storie paurose ecco
vedi quel libro è un oggetto o
straordinario dagli sono uscite molte
creature anche io sono uscito da tu sei
il sito da questo libro come hai fatto e
è un po complicato da spiegare e
praticamente
in quel libro io sono stato catturato e
anche altri altre creature sono state
catturate lì dentro con me sarò insieme
e adesso qualcuno mi ha liberato come
potete immaginare non hanno liberato
solo me ma anche altre creature quindi
le altre creature sono in questo libro
sono state liberate
esatto voi sapete che creature sono in
questo libro vero ma aspetta un momento
tu sei un lupo buono quindi si si
considera mi un tuo alleato un tuo amico
ok è un po strano
wow un mezzo lupo a fluido è puro nostro
alleato adesso cosa dovremmo fare noi
quello che dovete fare è cercare le
creature e catturarli in modo da
completare le schede creature del libro
completare le schede creature del bbt sì
perché sapete che nel mio libro fiori
paurose ci sono le schede creature con
tutte le informazioni delle creature
spetta fahmy controllare non c'è più
l'illustrazione della creatura non c'è
più quindi dobbiamo catturarla dentro al
libro ma come facciamo a ritrovare le
creature scappate dal libro esattamente
come avete fatto a trovare me immagino
che vi abbia portato il libro e il libro
mi condurrà dalle altre creature ho
capito ti ricordi che il libro ci tirava
e ci stava tirando verso la porta e
quindi sarà libera condursi dalla
creature ma oppure no non mi conduce da
nessuna parte il libro è però però non
tenerlo così vicino a me per me no non
aprirlo con me vicino sono catture di
stime ho capito tu sei uscito dal libro
quindi potrei ricatturare te dentro al
libro sì ma questo non deve succedere
sono un po troppo aiutarvi hai ragione
allora dobbiamo iniziare la nostra
ricerca delle altre creature il più
presto possibile se non calcoliamo le
creditori beh se le lasciamo va in giro
libere cosa potrebbe succedere potrebbe
succedere per esempio che un bambino
potrebbe mordere e tante altre persone e
poi tutte queste persone insieme tutti
questi bambini insieme si
trasformerebbero sarebbe molto
complicato poi ti creerebbe un esercito
di vampiri
esattamente non possiamo fare in modo
che questo succeda da dove iniziamo a
cercare il libro non mi sta dando nessun
segnale ancora
[Musica]
e
credo che sia un po umano un po'come e
cioè in un po ma anche un matto
beh forse è meglio se lo lasciamo
tranquillo guardare gli uccellini eh si
sembra ti piaccia tanto osservarle ma
marino non si è accorto di niente è il
signor next lupo si sai che noi abbiamo
un cane che dorme o meglio esemplare
ciao piccolo
noi siamo quasi colleghi siamo quasi
colleghi io mi dice quattro zampe
ciao
lo sapevo noi diventeremo tanto amici
berlino è felicissimo
sì adesso mi riconosceva per sempre
un amico
insieme al
libro ci sta portando verso di la testa
seguite
ma sei sicura unità ma sei sicura che
dobbiamo andare lassù è un po buio è il
libro si sta guidando la sua dobbiamo
cattura nella creatura qualsiasi
creatura essa sia non possiamo lasciarla
libera
e mysky ancora debole in fila di limone
youtube c'è qualcosa da sopra magari
posso venire unica come sto arrivando
ora
dove sei
se si può la vita sta soffrendo di
capire dove potrebbero ma penso che
siamo nel posto giusto però non mi dice
dove esattamente si dobbiamo seguire i
suoni i rumori si ottima idea
da dove veniva ma soprattutto che
creatura starà tra le mie creature del
libro controlliamo
dietro al divano sotto i cuscini e
internet una panatura se nessuno andava
dietro
così alzarsi creatura no ma c'è la
creatura qui non segnerebbe un modellino
produrrà un tempo di
il primo
quarto abbiamo cercato una creatura
break con un frigo molto
delicati che può servirci a vestire
giocando mio intervento qualcosa
se ne andò ti servirà per trovare la
rete del fronte sulla costruzione
piccioni e torcia che bella questa
io credo questa io metto festa che non
funziona
non sembra niente questo è
sicuramente quello si nasconderà di
allora creatura sarà una mini creatura
forse il fantasma dell opera che si
nasconde davvero
non c'è niente un teatrino e hanno
effettivamente non c'e nulla fatene tuoi
libro magari attendi che era una strada
giusta
ottima idea che ti affido la lampadina
che non funziona né una lampadina e una
tracciando una torcia che non funziona
allora ok libro ti puoi guidare le
creature
ci sono due porte su quale porta andiamo
[Applauso]
ufficiale per dimitri buttato sul divano
e sono stato io e chi proprio che sotto
arrivando adesso che visto un po il
perimetro della stanza potresti
impiegarmi dove la creatura
sembra di sì se ho incollato qui su
questa volta ti pronto sì andiamo a
scoprire che cosa c'era dietro 3 2 1
ok
e
continuano voi anche problema meno in
questa casa ancora tu è il mare stavamo
cercando la creatura che ci fai tu qui
di nuovo in bagno dopo tutto questo
tempo ho bisogno di andare al bagno
vetro questo non creando invenzione ma
cosa state aspettando andate a cercare
la creatura lasciatemi in pace è il
libro che ci ha condotto quattro date
perché perché tu sei una creatura è
quindi ci porta da te ma mettiamo
giocando l'altra creatura di ciao ciao
video avvio
prima dove dobbiamo andare
va bene va bene ti lasciamo imparato
speriamo se dobbiamo trovare questa
creatura si batte fino
alla professione
e lui giu io vado a controllare se
merlino bisogno del mio aiuto
forse berlino trovato la creatura
stato perso qualcosa
[Musica]
era tutto il tempo con occhi in questa
porta la creatura non in quell'altra
porta ora non c'è vitale però ma vabbè
provo a vedere se disco io a catturare
la creatura con il libro vediamo
innanzitutto che creatura è pronti
no
[Musica]
nessuno
ehi
creatura
dove sei
chi sei che cosa sei che creatura 6